one of the most powerful and celebrated
men in Opera faces allegations of sexual
misconduct that spans several decades
numerous accusers told The Associated
Press Placido Domingo tried to pressure
them into sexual relationships by
dangling jobs and sometimes punishing
them professionally when they refused
his advances that mingo says the claims
are inaccurate Nicky batiste is here
Nicky what else are we learning about
these accusations
good morning Anthony good morning
everyone we're learning a lot of details
Placido Domingo is regarded as one of
the greatest opera singers and
conductors of all time but the 78 year
old is now facing a number of
accusations of sexual harassment and
abuse eight singers and a dancer told
The Associated Press they were sexually
harassed by Domingo over three decades
beginning in the late 1980s the accusers
alleged the account urse happened at
venues that included opera companies
where Domingo held top managerial
positions one accuser said Domingo stuck
his hand down her skirt three others
said he forcibly kissed them Domingo is
a multi Grammy Award winner and director
of the Los Angeles Opera only one of the
nine accusers would allow her name to be
used
Patricia Wolff sang with Domingo at the
Washington opera he would be in the
wings waiting for me and he would come
up to me this close and he would say
Patricia do you have to go home tonight
you also think as soon as you walk away
and get away you think did I just ruin
my career Domingo has issued a statement
saying in part the allegations from
these unnamed individuals dating back as
many as 30 years are deeply troubling
and as presented inaccurate I believe
that all of my interactions and
relationships were always welcomed and
consensual none of the women could offer
documentation of the alleged encounters
but The Associated Press spoke to many
colleagues and friends who they can find
it in the AP also independently verified
the women worked where they said they
did and that Domingo overlapped with him
at those locations the AP also noted
that these women did not want to
disclose their names for fear
retribution still in the
it's a wiggle room there in the
statement the the accusations as
presented oh yes to be interesting
interesting to see what happens and you
are asking these women say they are now
coming forward because they're empowered
by the me2 movement like so many others
for Jane it's a very familiar story
thank you very much Nick